as a Storyteller I want to give
audiences something they've never seen
before the book of Clarence is about a
man's journey of self-discovery clar is
a dreamer he has Ambitions in his life
and wants to do bigger and better things
and bring happiness to his family but
he's a man without faith knowledge is
stronger than
belief Clarence conceives of the idea
that by personating the Messiah I can
see I can see he can attain wealth and
that begins his journey that helps him
find faith is a beautiful soul in there
somewhere the book of Clarence it's not
about the Bible it just runs alongside
it Clarence is dealing with finding
himself and his connection to God and it
being showing another veneer of black
skin I think gives it a unique flare and
perspective I got the cobblestones
unlock you hope when you go to see a
movie that you're going to be on the
cusp of something that is new exciting
James is always trying things and
pushing things in a New Direction
James's enthusiasm is infectious and
it's in the film bring in the prisoner
you don't always have to shout he's a
musician music is the essence of
everything really and it made its way
into the story from the very
beginning it's a film that the audience
hasn't seen before a lot of people say
that but this guy actually does that the
set all the actes costumes everything
comes to life Rel the book of Clarence
is fun it's tears it's pain it's drama
it's
Joy it's Banner of a
movie oh damn you put it like
that